- [Christian] Modern furniture began
at the Bauhaus 100 years ago.
There have always been only
a few serious companies
doing Bauhaus furniture
re-editions or replicas.
We are doing this for 50 years now.
It's important for us to tell the story
how it really was.
- [Narrator] This is Tecta,
a factory in Lauenförde, Germany-
one of the few in the world
to replicate original Bauhaus furniture.
And this is one of the
crafters behind it all.
- My name is Christian Drescher.
I'm the owner of Tecta.
We are a family business
fourth generations,
and I co-work with my
uncle, Axel Bruchhäuser,
for the last years.
- With my father and I, we
took over the existing company,
Tecta, and our dream was to produce
all the forgotten Bauhaus furnitures.
- Our aim is to prove everyday
that these classics still play a role
in current living situations.
- The centenarian designs
are known for their minimal
and practical nature and lack
of adornments and details-
central features in the Bauhaus school.
And these men are on an intricate mission
to make sure that designs
like the 1925 Wassily Chair
and the 1927 Cantilever
Chair are still sat on today.
- Drawings and original
documentations are very important.
So we worked closely, or work closely,
with the Bauhaus archive
and then, from that on,
we can realize things; we
have a carpentry workshop
and a metal workshop, the upholstery,
put all these together,
together with the designer;
this makes it possible
to make the furniture.
It's a big satisfaction if
you see that you have somehow
prolonged the life-cycle of an old classic
by doing an interpretation of 2019
of a Bauhaus piece from 1919.
And then people say, "Wow,
this is so avantgardistic,
"this is so contemporary"
though it's 100 years old.
That makes us very proud
because they are not simple products.
They are furniture with a
soul with something more.
(light music)